voilà alors qu'août effet le monsieur je
vous ai dit comment il était donc vous
aurez pas inquiéter le commerce se fait
désormais par téléphone derniers
préparatifs suivant la liste précises de
la cliente
les produits frais dans la glacière et
le tout dans la voiture moi je pars dans
lignières en face de la mairie des
commandes retirer en boutique mais aussi
des dizaines de livraisons par jour à 5
km autour du centre de lignières et puis
les produits frais il ya 12 heures un
service souvent à destination des
anciens seuls chez eux le plus grand
bien parce que ça nous vous voyez comme
saluer dépanne bien monsieur qu'un sac
qui est responsable de l'épicerie la
avait pris l'habitude de livrer les les
personnes âgées donc temps et je pense
qu'il en soit ils s'en sont souvenus
qu'ils aient fermé son magasin ils s'en
sont souvenus et ils font appel à lui
aussitôt qu'ils ont su qu'il allait
rouvrir parce qu'en 2018 philippe
partait à la retraite l'épicerie était
donc fermée depuis deux ans mais début
avril
il n'a pas hésité à ouvrir mon concept
c'était de monter en urgence pour la
situation de deux corps à des virus là
ce problème là de monter en urgence une
possibilité de pouvoir offrir aux gens
des repas et surtout des produits frais
pour qu'ils aient un repas équilibré
pour le jeune retraité encore
propriétaire des murs il faut retrouver
les réflexes d'avant et nous avons six 6
si ce sera l'unité 6 x 16 centimes 0,16
le commerce
revis philippe veut maintenant passer la
main il ne manque plus qu'à trouver un
repreneur après la crise